VY chairman of babber District Council
and I will be chairing this meeting
tonight first of all may I remind you of
some domestic
Arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water is available in the
breakout area outside the meeting
room if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room by
following the first exit sign and meet
on the ipswitch Town Football Club
training pitch do not re-enter the
building until you're told it is safe to
so do please switch off all mobile
phones or turn them to
silent I'd like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you are
also consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training
purposes the council members of the
public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not Lo
aul excl
excluded now can I move to the
agenda we have apologies for
absence thank you chair we have received
apologies from Council John nun councel
deasa and councelor Margaret
mabery I'd like to draw uh council's
attention to the fact that councelor
mabery has been very ill I think she's
now been released from
hospital and it is understood that she
won't be able to join us until after the
new year so I would like to take this
opportunity to wish her on your behalf a
speedy
recovery thank
you Declarations of interests by
counselors the monitoring officer has
granted dispensations to all counselors
for consideration of the joint local
plan are there any other Declarations of
Interest
no moving on we move to item three
bc23 sl25 and this is to confirm the the
minutes of the meeting held on the 24th
of October 2023 for accuracy only are
there any issues with the
accuracy no can I have a proposal
please councelor Jameson and councelor
Plum seconding all those in
favor
okay that's
carried we now move on to paper
bc23
sl26 announcements from the chairman and
leader I refer you to this paper and it
is for noting thank you very
much I'd also like to invite councilor
Ward acting leader to make his
announcements thank you madam
chairman firstly swimming pool funding
we were pleased to hear we've been
awarded funding of £15,000 to help
offset increased utility costs at Hadley
pool and Leisure the successful bid came
from sport England Phase 1 swimming pool
grants funding unfortunately a first
round bid for funding to help the
Kingfisher leer Center in subre was
unsuccessful as councilors will know
swimming pools are particularly
dependent on energy use so inflation and
soaring energy bills have put ledure
providers under increasing Financial
pressure we obviously welcome this
funding and hope for further support in
the second round for all our pools and
Leisure centers facing the same
challenge next on the um support for
those impacted by the recent floods it
is a month since severe flooding h a
number of our communities and for many
of our residents the recovery
continues the government has announced
grants for homes and businesses that
were impacted 5 00 for homes and £2,500
for businesses to assist with initial
recovery costs babber District Council
has been working with neighboring
districts and suffet County Council to
get these grants to those eligible as
quickly as we
can we will be able to start
Distributing funding before the end of
this month now I'd like to remind
everyone that all reports of property
flooding need to be submitted via the
suffet County Council
website next new winter Grant you may
have seen the announcement earlier today
that we have launched a new living well-
in Winter Grant Grant to help
communities tackle issues like social
isolation and the need for warm spaces
this winter the funding means that the
councils can help communities tackle
social isolation and address the choice
that for some residents whether to heat
or eat is winter as the cost of living
crisis continues to take its toll
Community groups can apply for a minimum
of £500 and a maximum of
£2,000 applications are now open and can
be submitted until Sunday 17th of
December next I just wanted to touch on
South Cambridge here you will all
probably be aware now that suffk bur and
District leaders wrote an open letter of
support to the leader of South cambri
District Council Bridget Smith regarding
their trial of a 4-day working week this
is not about the merits of otherwise of
a 4-day week but it is about local
autonomy this is a matter for a local
Authority alone and the government
shouldn't intervene it sets a dangerous
precedent and councils must be allowed
to make their own informed decisions the
decision decision to serve a best value
notice is heavy-handed and tantamount
bullying the council must now answer up
to 80 questions totting 186 individual
requests from government every week
which will be very timec consuming and
costly to do they also have to provide
cost and performance data going back to
2018 it is a misuse of the best value
notice process and no evidence that one
is necessary has been provided councelor
Smith was very grateful for our support
and thanked us for what she said was an
incredibly kind and helpful letter
and finally you will have received an
email from councelor James Giles of the
royal bar bar of Kingston at the weekend
asking you to sign a letter regarding
the situation in Gaza on behalf of an
organization called counselors for
ceasefire the tone of the email has
caused a lot of worry and fear for many
and the LGA chairman councilor Shawn
Davis has sent out an Urgent Message
reassuring us that no contact date was
supplied by the
LGA however I know that some of you are
concerned by the small print at the end
of the email email which states you are
receiving this email because you opted
in Via our website and I have written to
councelor Davis to seek
clarification this is further
Complicated by councelor Giles sending
his email from his Kingston email
address and I will update you when I
have further
information thank you
chairman councel hold
yeah councilor would mention the letter
to South campers here um obviously all
members weren't consulted on that and it
is somewhat um surprising that a letter
sent on behalf of us all on such a topic
uh it certainly came out in the press
that it was on behalf of the council
which represents all of us and none of
us have consulted on that and going
forward I'd like to think that we could
all be consulted on things similar to
that we all might not agree I personally
don't
um so I just think there's a note that
perhaps he could take forward when
sending out emails like that and letters
of
support okay Council
Lord you
okay right moving on to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with Council procedure
rules non received chair thank you
questions by the public in accordance
with the
council procedure
rules n Reed chair thank you we now move
to item seven which is questions by
counselors in accordance with the
council procedure
rules I refer you to the questions in
the tabled papers I would now like now
like to invite councilor beer to ask his
question thank you madam chairman good
evening uh my question is to councelor
Sally Dave as Cabinet member for planon
our mission is to provide strong proud
and inspirational leadership striving
for excellen and together building great
communities for everyone to live in work
visit and invest
in can the cabinet member for planning
councelor Sally Davis please inform us
how many homes have the planning
committee approved for construction
since the 4th of May
2023 and and similarly how many have
been occupied if possible thank
you thank you I'd now like to invite
councelor Sally Davis to
respond thank you councelor
be uh bab's planning committee have had
two applications for housing since the
election in May 2023 one for a single
dwelling and one for 43 dwellings both
were
refused however we have ised issued
planning permissions for over 800
dwellings since the election and
planning officers under delegated powers
have approved 64
dwellings thank you councilor beia would
you like to ask a supplementary
question uh yes Madam chairman was the
figure 800 can you just give me that
again
sorry
um right the
800 planning permissions that you've
issued they weren't the result of the
planning committee since the 4th of May
no so that isn't part of what I asked
you then thank you um so if we've not
approved any since May I believe in our
policy Madam chairman it is 300
416 that that babber is expected to
provide um towards the government's
total is this correct and at the rate
we're going on is there's a minimum
because the
880 are nothing to do with the question
that I asked thank
you thank you councelor Davis would you
like to respond yes well it's not that
we haven't approved any since the
elections as I say planning officers
have approved 64 dwellings since the
election for the year April to March
2023 there were over 600 completions
that's against the annual requirement of
416 as you rightly said um and picking
up the second part of your question
about occupation we've seen
347 homes completed for occupation since
the
election thank you I'd now like to
invite councelor Riley to ask his
question thank you mad chairman
there we are
right so bab M saf are advertising for a
political assistant to support the new
green admin green party
administration at an exciting time not
my words theirs an exciting time for
mids saach District Council so can we
please confirm that no cost for this
post will fall on the taxpayers and
residents of babber and that any
recruitment by babber for a similar post
will come to the full Council for
approval prior to the post being
advertised Council Ward would you like
to respond yeah thank you yes I must I
I'm rather pleased you qualified um your
use of the word exciting because I I was
a bit surprised when I saw that in in
the written version because um uh I was
surprised and I'm sure the greens would
been in equal measure mused and
delighted if if if you um starting out
on a new political
Journey don't think
so but
um we'll have to wait and see what the
another news headline tomorrow's press
is and we'll see um anyway but in
response to the first part of your
question although the two councils are
working together in a very successful
partnership we are separate councils
with our own budgets and spending
programs the political assistant is
solely a mids suff matter and covered
within their budget no part of it will
be financed by
babber just as the mids suffer report
went to their Council in September the
same would apply to us should it be
proposed for babber I must stress at
this point that we have no plans to
follow I'm not convinced of its value
and we can't afford
it thank you coun Riley would you like
to ask a suppl question thank you madam
chairman what's happened why are we so
concerned for the taxpayers famous
residents of B all of a sudden I I are
you asking I am I am I I I am sorry um
these weren't the answers I expected and
uh and I'm grateful for that as well
actually I'm going to stand down I'm
going to leave the answer as it is thank
you councelor ward thank you councelors
yes
was moving on we now move to paper B
sl23
sl27 babber and midu Joint local
development
scheme I would like to invite councelor
Sally Davis to introduce the paper and
to propose the recommendation in the
report thank you
chair I will shortly be asking Council
to adopt part one of the joint local
Plan before I do that I must ask you to
approve this document the Baba and mids
joint local development scheme for the
years 2023 to
2026 it's essentially a work program it
sets out the timetable for the next
stages of preparation relating to Parts
one and part two of The Joint local plan
we must agree this updated timetable
before we can adopt part
one in the local development scheme you
will see the council will be revising
the community infrastructure Levy
charging schedule in plain English that
means we must decide whether to increase
the levy or fee we charge developers
when they build on the land in our
district this Levy funds the
infrastructure to support such
development and in the coming months we
will review
this the local development scheme also
sets out nine supplementary planning
documents these will provide more
detailed guidance on the policies set
out in part one of the local
plan we've introduced an additional
supplementary planning document on air
quality to provide further detail on
assessing the impact of air quality on
sensitive
environments a supplementary planning
document on renewable and low carbon
energy will set out our expectations in
relation to solar farms and other
renewable energy planning
applications this local development
scheme replaces the current one adopted
in October
2022 and councilors will see that it
clearly shows the anticipated time
scales for the preparation of planning
documents up to the adoption of part two
in December
2026 so I propose the council agrees the
recommendations as set out on page 18 of
the report thank
you councelor Davis Do you have a
seconda
thank you councelor ward we'll now move
to questions councilors may ask as many
questions as they wish however they must
be relevant to the subject under
discussion and must be a
question so do I have any questions
councelor
Busby uh yeah Sor you said it was
completion December
26 according to the Gant chart it's 25
I would have thought 25 was more
realistic um we submit it to the
planning inspector in June
2025 and uh it will be ready for
adoption in uh December 20126 so that's
the planning inspector's timetable we
have to stick to there it's very
long
yeah okay thank you any any more
questions well it looks as if questions
have finished we'll now move to the
debate councilors will only be allowed
to speak for one uh speak once and for
three minutes and it will be timed so
who's going to open the
debate Council a
ward um there's nobody yeah just a few
words um this is a very important
document because it does set out the
timetable and the work program for the
next two to three years um I'm very
pleased that we we've now updated this
but we must and and the issue that I
think we all really understand is
there's a huge amount of work here not
just for the local plan part two but for
the 10 sbds and for the C charging
schedule there's a massive amount of
work that needs to take place over that
that period of time we want to avoid
slippage as much as possible it's got to
be managed very tightly it's going to
need very high degree of of um uh of
project management to make sure that we
keep to this timetable because any
further slippage um really I think is
something that we none of us wants to
see particularly with the the part two
of the plan because that's going to have
all the important information in about
uh spatial distribution site allocations
Etc so um uh I'm pleased with with the
the LDS that we've got but I think um I
recognize I think we all recogniz a very
challenging timetable yeah thank you
chair anyone else for debate councelor
halt yeah picking up on Council Ward's
comments I I notice the subject and
scope um hierarchy settlement housing
requirements figures for the
neighborhood plans we've got a lot of
neighborhood plans coming on at the
moment and a lot of this detail is going
to affect the current ones that are in
place and also the ones going through
the process of of developing so I'm very
conscious that a lot of people people
are putting a lot of effort into
neighborhood plans at the moment and
part two could affect how those
neighborhood plans would eventually be
uh put out and the alterations they
might have might have to have put in
place when part two comes into place so
I would urge all officers to make sure
they theas with Parish councils to
ensure they're kept up to date with all
the important information when they're
compiling putting together the
neighborhood plans so that we don't
waste Paris council's valuable time and
volun time in putting these plans
together thank you anyone else for
debate or can I take it that we've
concluded the debate councelor Davis do
you wish to add
anything yes I just say thank you to the
two counselors for their comments I'm
we're obviously um extremely aware that
we must meet this timetable there are
things the things we can control are you
know are planned for there are some
things like like dealing with external
bodies that are possibly not in our
control but we're I know that the
offices are looking to take that into
account and absolutely the part about
neighborhood plans is absolutely vital
so thank you thank you I'll now ask the
assistant manager governance to conduct
the electronic
vote thank you chair uh that vote is now
shown in Blue on your app you might have
to scroll down a
bit
councelor bear may I take your vote
pardon approve thank
you councelor o may I take your vote
please thank
you councelor Riley may I take your vote
please approved thank thank
you counselor okay oh thank you no
problem that's 21 uh 29 votes for and um
that's unanimous
chair thank
you
23428 babber and mids suffk joint local
plan for
adoption I'd like to invite councelor
Sally Davis to introduce the paper and
to propose the recommendation in the
report this is a rare moment it's it's
not every day that a council is invited
to adopt a local plan it's taken seven
long years to reach this
moment I'm new to my role and I've not
been part of this long arduous
Endeavor so I am nowhere near as excited
as the officers in this chamber look at
them they're beside themselves with
excitement and anticip councel are
they're really jumping about AR they
they just hold it back so yes work on a
joint local plan started in summer
2016 and the plan has been through three
different versions and extensive
consultation before the examination by
the planning inspectors which began in
2021 I would like to thank the officers
who have brought the plan to this point
in particular the plan planning policy
team who've spent many days months and
years ensuring the plan is
sound I particularly thank Robert Bert
Hobbs a man with a formidable grasp of
detail who has navigated through this
highly complex process with dogged
determination and I am sure he's going
to continue to do so for part
two thanks also to Tom Barker who has
overseeing this plan throughout thank
you and I pay tribute to my predecessor
counselor Clive arthy who worked
extremely hard with unfailing commitment
to Shepherd through this part of the
local plan there are many officers and
councilors who have been involved and I
thank them
all the planning system shapes what
development can happen where done well
planning ensures that the right
development happens at the right place
in the right time benefiting communities
the environment and the
economy decisions on development affect
all of us that's why it cannot be left
to private individuals to decide what
happens where so the planning system is
a Cornerstone of
democracy and a local plan is a key
document it sets out a vision and
framework for the future development of
an area Consulting with a range of
organizations and communities in doing
so local plans address needs and
opportunities in relation to housing the
local economy Community facilities and
infrastructure the government says they
should safe guard the environment enable
adaption to climate change and help
secure high quality accessible
design it provides a degree of certainty
for communities businesses and investors
and a framework for guiding decisions on
individual planning
applications so on the 19th of September
2023 the planning inspectors the gods of
the local plan Universe concluded that
the Baba and midu joined joint local
plan part one is
sound this means the plan is positively
prepared Justified effective and
consistent with national planning policy
so we are now able to consider adopting
the plan because the inspector says it
is
sound the adoption of the plan is a
significant Milestone it means babber
District Council will have an up-to-date
planning framework to guide development
up to
2037 planning officers and the planning
committee will use the plan to inform
their decisions it will be relied upon
at
appeals so the joint local plan part one
with the modifications Incorporated is
appended in appendix a and the main
modifications are summarized in the
council report and detailed in the
inspector's report at appendix
B adopting The Joint local plan part one
enables The Joint local plan part two to
progress as set out in the local
development
scheme I propose that Council adopts the
bab and mids suffk joint local plan part
one and agrees the recommendation at
page 22 of the
report uh do I have a seconder please
Council
award we'll now move to questions as you
know you can ask as many questions as
you wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and must
be a question question any
questions I know it's Dan thank you
councelor
Davis uh one of the modifications you
have on biodiversity which can be found
on lp16 Section e uh regarding achieving
biodiversity net gain of 20% originally
from
10% what in your mind is it more
political will than anything else that
would prevent a target of 20% being
achieved um thank you councelor Potter
yes um in the joint local plan part one
um the there is a minimum requirement of
a 10% biodiversity net gain on any
development um that's the minimum and
that really only just holds the line
what we will be looking at in the
supplementary planning document on
biodiversity and trees is looking to
make that
20% um and we'll be um uh investigating
how we can make that happen because for
every tree we knock down for every hedge
we grub up for every Green Field that we
dig up we destroy valuable biodiversity
and we must replace it and not only
replace it but we must put it back even
more because we have lost so much
biodiversity over the past decades so
10% is not enough and we will be looking
to put 20% in a supplementary planning
document thank you councelor
Riley thank M
chairman The Joint local plan runs for
14 years and yet the next this year and
the next three years we look like
running a deficit of about6
million can you tell me or confirm to me
that the development plan will
acknowledge that we have debts to the
past and you know requirements for the
future and please tell me
that we intend to make babber of an
affluent community and not one that's
living beyond its
means I'm going to refer that question
to the officers I don't feel qualified
to answer that
question
through you chair um the plan aims to
deliver sustainable growth throughout
the plan period it plans from 2018
through until
2037 um the councils have delivered
through planning permissions already a
significant number of the dwellings that
are required across the plan period um
over 90% of those dwellings that
required across the plan period already
have planning permission so babber is
currently um holding a number of extant
plan and permissions that can be
implemented over the next two three four
five years and Beyond so we're confident
that bab will be able to serve the
housing needs that are required
throughout the plan
period
you question
finished we'll now move to debate
to repeat you can only speak once and
for three minutes who'd like to open the
debate councelor
Holt thank you chair um whilst I welcome
jlp 1 uh we must not forget this was not
a success the inspectors pulled it apart
and as a result we have JP to if we'
have been standing here today with a
complete local plan I think we could all
agree it would would have been a success
even though it had taken be while to get
there but I hope and I'm reassured by
Council David's comments that during the
coming years until the end of 20125 when
when our term ends
um not
2025 TR thank you um that we will be a
long way along the road to having jp2 in
place um but as I say we must not forget
that we should be celebrating a complete
plan now and we're not thank you anyone
else
councelor Jameson then councelor Ward
okay um yeah I'd like to Echo councelor
Hal's comments that you know this this
isn't a perfect
plan um there are a lot of things there
that could have been better and is has
as cast said hasn't um been a success
over the last few years the amount of
time it's taken and the problems that
we're experiened but um we are where we
are and um we do need we do need a plan
we've got to have a plan and I will be
supporting the plan definitely yeah
we've got to remember that it wasn't a
success and hopefully with the
supplementary planning documents we can
make
improvements where they're needed thank
you thank you Council
Ward yeah I I I would take issue with um
Council H saying it's hasn't been a
success um it's very the whole process
is very very difficult we all know that
uh councils up and down the country have
been struggling with the process and it
is very very difficult to satisfy the
examiners on on this um yes we've got a
two-part plan but um that was a
pragmatic uh uh decision and and um
option given to us by the examiners
we've now proceeded we're in this stage
where we can approve part one and let's
not diminish the uh the uh import of
that part one contains 10 strategic
policies 32 development policies these
are crucial for controlling how
development takes place in our districts
going
forward whatever you may think about the
split between part one and part two this
is really a momentous moment for both of
our councils and it does show the power
of working together and it's what our
partnership is all
about so I think we're in a great
position now we we've got new Clarity
over development policies for our
planning committees going forward and so
uh not withstanding some of the the
limitations with with the part one which
we all know and and has been mentioned
so far is not perfect but it is a great
way uh great Improvement on what we've
had before on the core strategy and all
all of our policies from the previous
local
plan I would like to just say one final
thing and um this is um councelor Davis
has has mentioned this and that is I
wanted to talk talk a bit about Clive
Ary Clive um when he became a planning
portfolio holder he did promise me that
he would see the local plan delivered
unfortunately he had didn't manage to
achieve that before the election in 2023
but he got a huge Way Forward and the
fact that we are here today debating
this and uh hopefully approving it this
evening adopting it this evening is is
in a large part down to him as far as
I'm concerned this part one is Clive's
Legacy thank you
chair um councelor Davis you have
a comment
yeah yeah thanks so first of all I'll
endorse the comments about councilor Ary
because he did an absolutely amazing job
um I remember this going back to the
core for sites 2015 2016 it's been a
long and arious process there's a couple
of points I want to make first of all I
wonder how different it would have been
if it had just been a baba local plan
and I think it's a cautionary tale about
um us and mid suffer coming together
because as the inspector pointed out
there's a lot of issues came along with
that um and I and I think it would have
been a lot different if it had just been
babber I think all the hard work that's
got into it shows how much scrutiny has
taken place in there as well um and our
residents can be uh somewhat assured and
I I totally appreciate councel point
it's not a perfect success but our
resident should be assured that this has
been looked at in real depth and detail
therefore the next day just to make sure
that the work that the officers in
particular councelor Barker and councel
Hobs have done are not wasted by
ourselves when our planning committees
get together and indeed the offices they
need to be fully trained and they be use
this document to its absolute full
advantage and not and not miss the
opportunity we need to make sure our
residents are well served by the
document I will be supporting it
obviously and well done to the officers
and again to C and thank you for
presenting
it and then councelor
Haren thank you chair um yes addressing
this point about part one and part two
we were all surprised when it came back
to say we're got to the inspector wish
to separate it into Parts one and two
but I'd like to point out there are
actually some advantages here the sheer
length of time um which we've been
watching or looking at this plan six
seven years however you count it has
meant that some of the call for sites
the allocations made May in fact have
been superseded by events and in fact a
a new call for site is Thoroughly
Justified we're also supported by the
fact that we have sufficient housing
permissions to supply us with housing
for S years according to uh the
requirements that's made of us this
gives us a chance to continue with these
supplementary planning documents and I
just suggest that had uh part two being
adopted today some of the points that
people members particularly in the green
party here would like to include in uh
the supplementary planning documents
would not have had a chance to be
considered well they will now and I
don't see anything wrong in us spending
a little bit of time and doing that in
the meantime we have part one planning
committees can use it we no longer have
the struggle that the problems of
dealing with the conflicts between CS2
and cs11 and which policy applies here
and which policy applies there we have
relative simplicity so I think there's
an absolute no-brainer and um I will
also Echo the comments made about
councelor arthy um but I would actually
commend everybody involved in the entire
process because I've been there all the
way through it and I'm really glad it's
over thank you you councelor
Haron yes thank you Madame chairman my
um um query is partly question I suppose
mainly for
clarification um recently since the
spring the government have launched a
light touch neighborhood plan and babber
is um contributing and working with that
and I've just wondered how the team
think um that can be incorporated into
the final joint local plan there are
five villagers who have gone for this
route and four of them are in my ward um
three probably joined together and one
um just outside so I'm just wondering as
we develop it's probably a question for
the officers more than councelor Davies
but um what weight will this new light
touch plan have and how will it be
incorporated into the um The Joint local
plan for the two councils thank you
thank
you I think that's the debate
concluded oh no not at all um councelor
Busby and then councelor
Riley uh thank you chair um I have some
concern actually with this whole process
what concerns me is it's going now going
to take us three years to do stage two
that's three years with living with our
existing approved applications my
concern is that we're desperate for
social housing housing that people can
afford but I'm not convinced that the
applications that we've already got
approved will deliver those social
houses and not having a stage two in in
place for three years means that we're
going to be waiting some time before we
can actually get that social housing I
think we've got to be very careful on
our planning the way we deal with it how
we can deliver social housing because it
is a desperate need throughout the
district thank you councelor
Riley concerned when I start hearing
people say that um we can't allow the
private sector to run R because can't
let the public sector private sector r r
but we should be working with the public
with the private sector Council Ward
talks about control this is very um
socialist that we are you're the one to
say control sir we can go back to the
yep use control anyway we'll move on all
right you um what we need to ensure in
these plans coming forward and their
implementation is that we are open for
business that we make babber an
attractive place to be both in the
planning procedures and the planning
policies and that's my point you know I
don't want to see the documentation the
policies the procedures under protocols
get in the way of our doing business all
these things are important because they
assist us in going forward not get in
our way and that's all I've got to say
thank you very much um Mr Barker I got
the impression that you wanted to
clarify uh councelor Busby's
interpretation
a um it might be easier to take outside
the meeting but of course the the plan
that you are potentially approving
tonight does not um preclude you from
granting planning permissions in
accordance with the policies within the
plan so you don't have to wait for part
two before you grant any planning
permissions for new dwellings there are
all sorts of policies Within part one
that would support new Housing
Development Within certain circumstances
so it's just to clarify that point
really thank you that's helpful yeah
councelor beer did I detect you wish to
debate I I was debating a point I mean
accept what my colleague here says about
B Bo business and I'm sure we are um but
could I just be assured because it's in
the plans the local plans somewhere that
the development of um
encouraging uh employment for people we
need need better jobs better skills so
that people can afford the affordable
houses that we're trying to provide for
them so can we be sure that while we're
going forward with the local plan that
we can somehow encourage better jobs and
skills for people because that's
important and unless we raise the um
earn and power up in this area we're not
going to be doing a service to our
residents thank you okay councelor Davis
you should only speak once during debate
but I'll allow it this time yeah so I I
just wanted to respond in my role as the
E economic portfolio holder and assure
councilor beer that every effort is
being made and um regeneration sites are
opening up you've seen U we had a recent
U one in Hadley which will bring
employment and there's many others going
on skills in Sudbury you'll seeing the
skill set there um and BR and
regeneration there is movement of such
or beit small at the moment so yes
you're absolutely right we need to bring
more skills and decent pay as well for
for everybody and so they can afford
even the affordables um and and and I
agree with Council buby about the social
housing as well but in terms of our
portfolio the economic regeneration
everything is being done and more we'll
be coming forward on that as well thank
you thank you to can the day just for
that
thank you I think debate is now
concluded no Dan sorry
Dan yeah just uh on uh part two of the
plan uh which I was quite pleased to see
particular my Bo with uh assessment of
house boat dwellers needs uh giving a
relevant development management policy
for house boo
dwellers and it's disappeared
disappeared from my screen but
nevertheless it is welcome and also the
air quality within the a NB sites of
course I will be voting for this
plan okay so it's very good promising
news in that part two of the
document thank
you concluded the
debate councelor Davis do you wish to
sum
up no nothing further to say okay that
means that uh we can now ask the
assistant manager governance to conduct
the electronic
vote uh thank you chair members that
vote is now showing in Blue on your
app councelor Owen may I take your vote
please counselor uh Riley may I take
your vote
please and councelor beer thank
you
that vote is now concluded and that is
29 nine votes for so that's carried
chair thank you very
[Applause]
much well done
everyone Now we move on to councelor
appointments and I'm not aware of any
changes to
[Music]
placings the next one is motions on
notice we have not received
any so I now um I'm pleased to inform
you that since there is no substantive
um
business the meeting on the 19th of
December is now
cancelled and we shall meet again on the
23rd of January 2024 at 5:30 and
therefore
at 1817 I declare the meeting
closed